bianca holman is live this morning over
at gilchrist orchard with a look at the
fall offerings there bianca we need to
start feeling like autumn even though
it's not actually feeling like autumn
outside good morning
i know it doesn't feel like it outside
you can see the sun is already starting
to rise here but it smells like it in
this kitchen you guys it just makes you
feel all warm and tingly inside i'm
joined by mark rubin so tell us you all
been doing these apple cider donuts for
10 years now how is this year looking
because you've all started and i hear
there was a line on saturday yes we've
had a busier than normal early crowd
but we're making the bigger donuts now
so
that could be part of it exactly and
people look forward to it you know they
bring their kids and i hear the kids
like which one do they like the glazed
or the sugar and spice it's about half
and half right now so by the end of the
season we'll know which is most
preferred i'm gonna take a guess and say
it's gonna be the cinnamon and sugar
well tell us about the process mark tell
us how it all goes down because y'all
get here around 4 am right we get here 4
o'clock we start making the batter and
then we just keep cranking them out so
that by 7 o'clock when we open
there's enough
donuts for people to have some fresh
doughnuts yeah and then we have tea down
here she's doing the glazed uh donut
down there right tell us what's in the
glaze so it's a cinnamon cream cheese
frosting like we've had every
every year that we've been doing this
and so
it's the same thing we're just putting
it on the donuts now because we used to
do the mini donuts and work better so
now we have a glazer for that all right
looking all good so tell people you're
only open certain days during the week
what are those hours how much do they
cost give us the details so we're open
tuesdays thursdays and saturdays from 7
00 a.m to 10 a.m right now
and then where uh the donuts are six
dollars for the cinnamon sugar or seven
dollars for six
at uh
with the frosting yeah all right well
looking good you know what i've had my
first one i'm trying to not eat them all
up and because again i haven't tasted
the glaze one just yet but me and my
photographer armando we split one and
don't worry about it you guys we're
gonna try to bring you a box right can
we bring the staff sure sure
all right well you heard it here be sure
you save some room on your tummy and get
some hot coffee to go with it send it
back to you guys in the studio